Okay, then a very warm welcome to the meteo evening.
Before we get started, I'd like to lay down a few quick ground rules.
Best if everyone mutes their microphone except me, and if you have questions you can use the chat down below.
Most of you know the function already.
Yeah, or there's the chat area where you can write something in.
But ideally we'd prefer the raise-hand button.
Then I'll see it and I can react to the question.
After about 40 minutes — actually a bit earlier — because this is a free version.
That means around 40 minutes is basically the end.
You'll also see a short break.
After that, when the time's used up, I'll send you a new link via WhatsApp
for the next session.
I think that's a good range.
I can't give you an exact schedule though.
It can happen that a few more questions come up and things run a bit longer.
Good, then I'd like to wait a moment.
What I'd like to do tonight is go through the individual apps I use,
one by one, looking at how they work,
or rather what the apps can do these days.
And what settings I've adjusted in some cases,
just to give you a better overview.
Just to give you a better overview, and at the end
we'll also go through the individual data again,
specifically for wind, clouds and the bigger weather picture.
So we'll do a concrete analysis there as well.
But first I'd like to walk through the individual apps in terms of how they function.
Then a bit more in detail regarding the forecast side.
Good, so I'll start there.
Sharing the screen.
Pressing share.
Good, then you should now see my browser.
Can you see it?
Yeah, as a browser maybe a quick reaction.
Do you see it now?
I still need to figure out the functions a bit, it's a bit awkward.
I think it's all good, wonderful.
Then let's go back.
Okay.
So this is the first one.
Windy — most of you already know it.
Before we go into the Windy app itself,
I'd like to show you the settings
I'd recommend you change,
if some of you haven't already done so.
And generally also for the wind.
I use km/h, temperature in Celsius,
and pressure in hectopascals.
Just basic settings here,
under the menu point up at the top right,
click that, then settings.
And on the main page, you can
make the settings there.
Wind animation normal or high.
High is okay.
The higher it is,
the more I feel
it gets cluttered,
the density I mean, the density.
The higher you set the density, the more
yeah, the more cluttered it gets, just try it out.
But if you set the animation to high
and the density a bit higher,
then you can distinguish stronger wind
or weaker wind a bit better
from my point of view.
And when you zoom in, you can already see
considerably more — more granularity
and considerably more wind.
Try it, make it a bit clearer.
I haven't had such good experience
with rain and thunderstorm,
or precipitation in general added in.
I have to be honest,
I haven't really seen it bring particularly good forecasts
for Switzerland specifically.
What's centrally important on Windy
is actually wind.
Now and then, especially abroad,
also clouds.
And the second most important thing on Windy
is definitely temperature.
That's a cool example,
especially today regarding Foehn maybe,
in trickier situations,
when it's less than 4 hectopascals,
to be able to read it off
by the temperature gradient between south,
the main Alpine ridge and north.
And always so that you can really read a proper
temperature gradient,
always set the altitude accordingly,
if you set this here on the right,
set the altitude to about 1000 metres.
And then for example you can see very well
the temperature gradient there
and I've actually had it work really
very strongly as well.
So as I was saying,
you can adjust the altitude here,
also for the respective wind,
for example, where you can choose,
of course that's very useful for us.
Very good.
We can go significantly higher
and zoom out a bit more.
It's clear that it deals with all elevations.
And you can really easily
spot strong wind bands,
if you now go to
a lower altitude,
where it gets a bit more interesting.
But maybe at 1000 metres once,
and then with one glance
you can spot wind very well on Windy.
So now this is the wind,
maybe in our area
and where I notice
the stronger wind band.
Is it nearby and worth
or do you see here,
looking,
or note well,
also at a low altitude of 1000,
just under 1000 metres.
Yeah, on the Plateau,
right?
So Windy for me
is actually already
a quite special display,
if you can really very broadly
see,
where there's less wind.
So I find it really neat,
and then it makes exactly that
very visible.
We also have
the option
to choose different weather models.
We have for example the option
to fade in city labels at the same time,
though that won't do much.
You can also have wind shown with direction
and especially with strength labelled.
But I'll make it
a bit cleaner again later,
because at the beginning
I always bring in very little general information.
What I've pre-set
to be permanently on
is the particle animation.
I think
that's the case for most of you,
but what you can also enable,
from my point of view sensibly,
are the isobars,
the lines of equal pressure.
And you can already read a lot from those.
And the cool thing,
down there with the date.
Alongside that, you can also look a bit ahead
and trust
how highs and lows will shift generally.
So I find that pretty neat.
You can really look far ahead,
get a sense of the whole picture for somewhere else.
That said though,
I wouldn't take it at face value,
anything more than three days out.
It's pure speculation for me, in that range.
But certainly good to have, from my point of view,
let's free that up,
the isobars,
I have those set on permanently.
And depending on the model,
there are different weather models.
You can also see
when they're updated,
you'd have to click the info button for that.
Then we have the respective models
with the grid that's being computed —
9 km grid, European model.
And then the whole thing is also updated,
at the corresponding interval.
Which is actually not bad,
the interval — then it's also,
okay, in about 13 hours the next update comes.
That means it doesn't really make sense
to check in every few minutes.
My conclusion,
is to spread that out a few times over the day,
spread out.
And take the info from there,
if we now go in there,
this one's coming nicely from the German Weather Service,
but it goes for all three bits.
And updated
at significantly shorter intervals.
But you might already notice,
the German model also doesn't cover such a large area,
if you're travelling somewhere else especially.
The European model with the 3.3 km grid doesn't.
Then you have to go a bit
larger again,
ICON EU with 3 km,
or with 3 km.
So those are the models.
I personally work at the start
to get an
overview, with the European model as a base.
I have a small advantage,
in our region for flying
or rather in the Alpine region,
I really, really like to use the ICON D2 there.
It fits the frequency very well
and in our region,
the forecasts really verify very well,
not always though,
but at least from our perspective.
We have the infos now,
you can dig those out and the different models,
then you'd have to figure out for your region as well,
by trial and error,
what works better for you, to figure it out.
Really, really cool — also over the whole week — is a general possibility,
to look at the weather in a more differentiated way, so not just the wind, but in general
an overview of everything, normally also for the region. Then there's an option
for a specific moment that you, normally that just opens up,
and there you've got, simply, where I see the sun, the cloud,
the ground faded in, you've got precipitation faded in, but
that's more for coarser forecasts. For our purposes specifically, you can
pull up forecast meteograms, or what's actually even a bit
better for us, because the wind, which varies with altitude, gets faded in too —
that's the so-called airgram. So you can see there the different altitudes
and it's actually really good and interesting. There too you can flip through the various
models, and then you get the forecasts from those. The American model
is the model that has been recording the longest — the most data available —
but it also has the largest grid at 22 km, and I actually only
use that one with care now, if I'm looking at a forecast a long way ahead, anything
and from my perspective that's become rather inaccurate by now, and now comes
a really cool function, the possibility — you go down here, I have
a function selected here, that's only possible if you've taken the subscription with Windy,
the biggest, I think 25 Euros annually, so really worth it — you have to decide for yourself
whether 100 percent or not, but now comes a really cool function, namely you can here
with 'compare' you can now compare all the models with one another for the corresponding day,
that means, if practically all models forecast
for tomorrow, we can assume that's also how it'll turn out, but if everyone
(unclear)
so
also
or
also as to which models work well at the chosen location.
But here I find another really, really cool function.
Yeah, if you're someone with a very specific feel, who wants to analyse thermals too.
That's a little trickier, but you really have to understand more of the emagram.
Let me just zoom in to show how.
And if I go here in our region onto the Drei Boden (Niederbauen), let me click into that.
Then it pops out, okay, click, and a grid opens up with various options.
And then you have to go all the way down to 'airology' and a function opens up for the emagram or rather,
so to speak — and I have it set to QT down at the bottom, you can use the normal one,
the longer normal one, or you can switch the whole thing to the other.
So that's what I still use, the one I've learned to work with.
And then you can actually analyse the temperature curve down there.
Those who can or need to can at least, based on the temperature curve of the dew point,
classify whether thermals are likely or not.
So this is set to the ECMWF model — cool, here you can really flip between the individual models.
And you can see that the German model already computes quite differently from the American one.
And what's actually very well visible for you is this good curve — you can see how steeply the curve goes up,
does the temperature decrease, or do we have an increase down below, so an inversion in there,
you can also check at a glance how far apart the temperature and the dew point curve are.
That means, is there less cloud formation, or is there permanent cloud formation up there?
With the feathers on the left, on the bar, on the higher line so to speak, there's also an indication of movement.
So there's actually a lot of information available, and you have to be able to read it off.
On the SkewT there are the temperature lines, where they're arranged diagonally and it also takes a certain time
until you've made yourself familiar with it.
But for me personally it's really the best tool now to get yourself prepared for the corresponding
day.
Good, so you see, actually plenty of, very, very much from one person.
For the wind, when you play through the individual altitudes, it's just a smaller grid,
the less far into the future you can look.
And on the other side, I'm also thinking about altitude.
It still goes here, but for the 1.3 km grid,
then to my knowledge you can only show ground wind.
Which now perhaps for cloud formation works fine,
if it's only about pure ground wind,
but for landings we don't really need much forecast data up above.
But depending on the grid, you can't look very far into the future.
Sometimes you start by always wanting to look far into the future.
Anyway, however far you can look ahead.
And then at least so you can do some planning,
and the European grid, and then depending on the location,
since I was in Spain recently, I had this on,
I took the ICON EU snippet.
Quickly to that.
And it worked in Spain too,
though in Spain, in terms of forecast,
it often didn't work well for me.
So you really have to test out, depending on the location,
how reliable the forecast is.
In India, super.
In Spain not quite so good.
Then the second app I'll get to in a moment was,
significantly better.
Let me say, the hit rate was really higher.
But again, as I said, zooming in and out,
and the area really also doesn't always begin from above,
so zooming further out,
and then to keep going into more detail.
That's an advantage for every forecast anyway.
Thumbs, no hands up.
All good, wonderful.
Okay.
Actually we do all of it, as I said,
as much as possible,
go through that too.
You can get a little lost in it.
Right now for clouds,
satellite imagery is recommended to add in.
But especially abroad,
very rarely matched,
take the forecast there really with caution.
You also can't go upward there.
If you wanted to look at this view,
because no forecast from the satellite image forms,
if you wanted to trust further into the future.
And it sadly didn't work so well,
abroad on a day like this,
like today,
with the team clouds,
coming in with their front,
the forecast is also accurate there,
but on days like that you have to use the satellite,
but so far I haven't needed it that urgently.
The same applies for...
That's a view for precipitation in general.
We'll get to that later with the other apps,
because I have it on there too.
Good.
Then I'd leave Windy
for once
and switch over to Meteoblue.
That would be
a mediator.
That's one of my absolute favourite apps,
because it just
in terms of presentation from my point of view
there's almost nothing better,
nothing easier,
nothing more clearly laid out,
than this actually,
we have 10 minutes
just got notified,
actually after 8 minutes.
And then later I'll
start a new session,
for sure.
The paid version,
if you use the basic or
the free version,
then there's an algorithm in there.
Any day,
or even if you save multiple dates,
that means, you don't know
which day,
it can be tomorrow,
it can be today,
you're basically,
if you permanently rely on it,
then you can do the basic,
but there too,
it costs 24 Euros,
for the whole year
which is actually very reasonably priced
and offers actually especially
for the normal pilot.
That was about all in there,
the forecast,
the wind forecast,
cloud amount,
precipitation amount,
thermal curves,
with colours,
in some places even strength.
So it's actually all there,
and above all,
yeah,
really very good.
What here,
and what I find really simple,
is the overall
overview to make.
Of course you can also further
zoom out,
but so for
a direct starting point,
where one is,
the Bise with cold wind,
into which I'm pointing,
done significantly better.
But,
when you go a bit into it,
and a little,
if he does that,
that he doesn't just
look at the location for you,
but perhaps also,
in the surrounding area —
pull it up.
That just happened.
Do you still have my screen?
Yes.
Could someone quickly indicate
and unmute?
Yes.
Okay, all clear.
You still have my screen.
I'll just film myself quickly.
As I said,
so,
not just for you,
oriented to that location,
but also the wind,
then in the surroundings around there.
And if you,
if you also open this on the doctor's screen,
but for you,
it looks like this.
And if you click on the diagram on the right,
then you get
the breakdown.
You have the altitude,
you've got the whole day with it.
So,
from 07:58 till the next morning
rolled out,
and not
to the wind at various altitudes
with bars,
from the
strength of the wind, the thicker, and now
clearly,
in the strength of the wind
even a little
of colour distinction marked.
So,
green and yellow,
still flyable,
and on orange flyable with care,
and then no longer flyable.
And I find that just
from the presentation
extremely good.
You can immediately at a glance
recognise
at what altitude there is,
incredibly good.
Or here,
for example,
the time,
then the wind,
extremely good.
What you have to watch out for with Meteoblue,
and have to be careful with,
just bear in mind,
you can easily subtract 5 to
sometimes 10,
sometimes even 15 degrees.
So,
I'd rather have it too strong,
but that's preferable to me,
than the other way around.
And,
what works very well for me
is the function,
direction.
And,
just yesterday,
as we had,
I got a message,
from Peter,
my Spain
is still on the road,
and there Meteoblue
delivered another absolute
pinpoint forecast.
So,
with the timing,
with the strength even,
and the wind direction,
then of course you can,
then also very,
very well,
work,
decide,
and go fly.
And Meteoblue,
I have to say,
is now spot-on for us,
even though it didn't used to be,
not all that often,
so well,
but abroad outstanding.
So,
if you go abroad,
is a Meteoblue,
absolutely necessary,
because it's extremely good in that case.
And,
the great thing is,
you have, with the time,
at a glance,
the cloud amount
or in the Stuttgart region,
where I had it set to,
that goes here,
the clouds,
when there's precipitation,
earlier going back
further,
where we should also have precipitation,
then it goes out,
the clouds,
in Stuttgart,
now,
from there further right down,
and then it goes underneath,
with precipitation,
with the time,
actually all of it on there,
and it's really at a glance
for the whole day.
It's gotten to the point now where,
this was at the beginning
with all of it,
but now it is so,
that I can look at it at the beginning
with the advance look.
And I find,
just visually from the presentation,
where you can quickly at a glance,
yeah, get an overview,
how it's distributed across the whole day,
where it's also been.
Now if you click on it,
yeah,
in winter it's actually super,
but,
if you now look at the whole
Thursday,
it just,
goes through each individual altitude.
That means, we have to,
what's the case at 2,000 metres,
or at 3,000 metres.
So we have to remember that.
Ah yeah, there, on the 6th in the evening,
for example,
there at 2,000 metres
to fix it up.
You really have to remember that,
and it of course takes a lot of time.
If you do the strong wind there again,
with 2,000 metres.
We've still got 2 minutes,
if you go up to 3,000 metres,
then we have at a glance,
we see immediately,
for example,
when the wind
down below,
picks up.
We have here maybe again at the lower-end view
in the wind-speed area
around midday,
we have a proper wind increase there
from the perspective of urges,
yeah,
also a storm,
really extremely coming through.
I find,
it makes it extremely quick,
right,
when,
when do we still have a problem?
Yeah, sometimes,
it's not a problem,
but rather,
when is it still unflyable?
And when do you really have to be careful?
I find that very, very good.
Then we have,
up at the top,
on the right,
next to us,
the airgram,
we also have the,
where we tell the thermals as well.
So, here too,
we can then of course also
the individual
switch,
to this KM hat,
let's go,
and in this high finds,
I have, as one does, here on the KM hat.
And here,
from my point of view,
again for the user,
due to the friendliness,
the emagram
has been modified.
That means, they've made their own
interpretation of this emagram.
Namely,
when you do it,
with this right state curve,
with its own colours,
to make it shumable.
That means,
it's actually a rather stable stratification,
because there's only a slight gradient,
decreasing very slowly,
or sometimes even staying constant.
We'd like to later
have it carried out together,
but I can on the Malten,
that it's now above,
as I've seen here over the H.
And how you actually approach
and light it not,
so that you've already got it calm,
you see,
you can really go there,
there we go again.
Are you satisfied,
you're already there,
you're okay.
How do you see,
huh?
So,
where you appear there,
you've got that in the other users,
so almost nothing left. Not even a minute. We'll then
stop in that case. Then later I'll get into this emagram once and respectively
the temperature with a few weeks. Let me end here and send.